[Music]
America fractured febrile furious old
wounds that have never healed pulled
apart in the middle of a pandemic a
country confronts the virus it's never
overcome racial division on the streets
of Minneapolis where George Floyd's
death lit this tinderbox
the protesters persisted undeterred by a
curfew with the police strikingly hard
to find the world is listening there are
opportunities for us to do that in a
constructive manner unfortunately there
are also those among us who would seek
to use this moment who would seek to use
his death as an excuse as a cover to
agitate for the destruction of those
same communities that have been most
traumatized by George Floyd's death but
in a society rich with inequity there is
anger at institutions
everywhere from Los Angeles to Colorado
and Kentucky
[Applause]
in Atlanta it was the CNN headquarters
targeted at the core of this although
unresolved rage at the disproportionate
number of African Americans killed by
police I'm mad as hell I woke up wanting
to see the world burn down yesterday
because I'm tired of seeing black in the
White House was also engulfed by
frustration the president warning
vicious dogs and ominous weapons would
have been deployed if protestors reached
the fence Derrick Chavan the officer who
put his knee on George Floyd's neck has
now been charged with third-degree
murder
but it's not enough for many this is a
nation in crisis rattled by dysfunction
smoldering with a leader currently
unable or unwilling to soothe Cordelia
Sky News Washington